I can do a B and C to fix the problem
right now do I have your permission
that's the person I'm looking for in a
company when we're hiring use this a lot
you here so right now we're talking
about CNN and we were talking about kind
of what's been going on with Cavanaugh
we've been talking for a long time
obviously but an tyfa and black lives
matter and here people often complaining
saying well someone has to do something
right we hear that all the time someone
has to do something i you know he was
asking when we do this kind of
pre-interview and he was asking me about
this show and what what it was it
inspired me to do this show this show is
the result of someone has to do
something
explain what that means and and this was
important because I have an email
recently from someone from the EF
conference and I appreciate the email
that you sent by the way life advice at
a lot of credit calm we'll be doing a
whole episode with nothing but life
advice that you probably won't want but
I remember a time when every
conservative I knew including myself
about how there was no conservative
light they're like where's a
conservative late-night how where's the
answer to the daily still often hear it
from people who watch cable news how the
left has a stranglehold on comedy
everyone kept saying that that we needed
some someone's got to do something and I
remember pitching this program now
whether you like this is not the point
whether you enjoy the program or not I
know many of you do not but you're here
anyway and I appreciate you suffering
through it with us I really do sometimes
I wonder why you watch but I appreciate
it I pitched this show day in and day
out at Fox News for four and a half
years and was told that it would never
work this very show what you see what
you know also by the way as change in my
mind was turned down by I think every
major conservative publisher everyone
all the ones that I can think of there
might be a few that didn't so I don't
want to drag anyone to the mud who
wasn't involved but at a conference
table
the phrase conservatives don't like
comedy they only want Obama doomsday
books right now were actually spoken sir
president so I think is important
because we often someone someone's
got--someone's got to do something we
have people even come up after the shows
of literally what was CNN with my
friends what if someone's got to do
something and in a more I don't want to
put point to anyone specifically they
were we're hiring right you can go to a
lot of credit come to see we're hiring
or moving the new space is expanding all
the time there are some people when we
were hiring very good people but you
know they
effectively just wanted to take part we
have like an 80% dropout rate I just
wanted to come and kind of work this
isn't this isn't for you this is the
kind of place where you do whatever it
takes
you grind until it's done because what
because somebody has to do something
it applies both ways if we stop if we
stop doing this show there's no one to
carry the mantle right now there's no
one else there's no one else is going to
provide this and we keep going we keep
putting ourselves through something that
obviously the wringer it's it's very
difficult and it's we're getting more
people coming in to do the program I was
talking with Ben about this they have
much more staff than we do but we do it
because someone has to do something this
is us doing something you know what
people can't stand complainers and this
is the someone someone has to do
something the person who just sits idly
by and says if somebody I'm gonna tie
this into a way that's hopefully helpful
it will will be helpful if you have ears
to hear you know people can't stand
complainers it's it's not just because
they're annoying but they are it's
because in complainers we see weakness
and in weakness we see untrustworthiness
we see betrayal the left loves to vilify
I was just talking about this with Gavin
McGinnis and this was what kind of
spritz was just talking with the left
they love to vilify the strong as toxic
let me ask you how many times have you
been betrayed in your life by a strong
man or a strong woman how many times
have you been backstabbed by the person
with the backbone the person who may be
a little bit tough to deal with might be
a little bit brash might be a little bit
blunt but gets things done how many
times have they screwed you over think
about it genuinely no it's the weak
among us who hurt us and we see weakness
and complainers someone who is about how
things shouldn't be so they can't
believe that things are this way you and
I we we also consciously say oh so
you're not doing anything to change that
it's so they're just waiting for
somebody somebody has to do something
that's in action and inaction is a
decision someone's got to do something
we hear that all time stop being the
person who says that be the person who
does something and let me tell you
something and as an employer because
what I'm about to tell you applies to
anyone in your life whose respect is
needed to be earned at all or or is
worth earning if there's anyone whose
respect you need to earn or you think is
worth earning this applies to you as an
employee the most valuable person to me
is the guy who comes to me with salut
two problems that I didn't even know
existed yet the most valuable the MVP is
the guy or girl who says I noticed this
wasn't working properly or I noticed
that this could be made more efficient
and I thought we can fix it through ABC
or XYZ I do have pure permission to do
so
I am the person looking tick looking to
give you more money are you men enough
to take it that's the person employers
are looking to promote and it applies to
every aspect of your life
from your work to your relationships to
your marriage to your finances you know
the least valuable person is in a
company it's the person who says problem
problem problem and doesn't give any
solutions and months down the line still
no solutions because anyone can find a
problem but when it comes to fixing it
by God somebody has to do something will
could that somebody be you know somebody
I mean somebody and me in the abstract
somebody finds away and these people do
this because the person who is trying to
do something also this is another
important component to the important
component of all someone's got to do
something the person who is trying to do
something if you become that person most
of you aren't by the way will inevitably
fail that's a part of being the person
who does something you know who never
fails the person who sits by and says
someone has so please think of the
children how about you think of the
children
someone has to do something and then
they can sit by and find more problems
and point to the failures of the people
who are doing something but in the long
run they're not the ones helping you
providing solutions not only are these
people less valuable in an employment
situation they cease to be valuable to
anyone in their life you know these the
problem finders this someone has to do
something guys eventually they find
themselves or herself cast out from
workplace society marriage their friends
sure that my band together like we're
talking about with Gavin McInnes and a
few others somebody got to do something
guys for a bit make themselves feel big
a mob mentality but that crumbles back
to the individual do something guy the
guy who says I can do X Y I can do this
I can do a B and C to fix the problem
right now do I have your permission
that's the person I'm looking for in a
company when we're hiring and you know
what so is everyone else it's not just
about that's the person your employer is
looking to promote that's the person
your friends are looking for and a true
friend that's the person your wife
looking for an a husband that's the
person you're probably looking for in a
wife that's the person your kids looking
for in a dad that's also the person gods
looking for in a disciple oh did I
strike a nerve did I strike a nerve with
all the nobility in poverty pious fake
Christians everyone whose respect is
worth earning is looking to bestow their
best their blessing upon the man who
does something period and I will tell
you this I was not that person for a
very long time I said up the fight
grateful for the opportunity i sat at
the foot of Fox News for years and put
on my stupid little polos and jackets
and hope that at some point someone
would do something and I was a fool and
now listen this isn't this isn't a
Tonight Show I get it I'm no Johnny
Carson but you know we've achieved some
relative success and that's entirely
because if you could all go away
tomorrow I'm incredibly grateful and
guess what it's a whole lot more success
and I had with any original show at 21
or 22 or 23 years old hoping that
someone would do something hoping that
someone would publish it look I've got
this treatment for the change my mind
book no no someone has to do this what
we are doing is this something I wish
someone had done that's all I can do I
can't do any better than that that's
like I can't we created a show we did
change my mind and I was talking with
with with bended with Dennis Prager
about this as well I said we did this
because we all set around saying the
conversations that we have when we go
get her hair is cut the conversations
that we have that have gotten us
unfortunately three and a half star
ratings at uber you never see on air
it's not about scoring political points
that's what changed my mind was it was
someone has to do something and I know
that at least at least millions of you
have benefited again I could all go away
tomorrow I'm very grateful
the reason this show exists at me being
31 years old that I was hoping to see
when I was 21 years old is because I
stopped at one point saying someone's
got to do something so the most the
question I most often get we will do
this life advice for people who are mug
Club members but can be answer really
simply with this as a starting point
often the questions are how do I do this
or how do I get started with this or hey
this is happening at school how do I fix
this or someone sees me this way it's
usually the same answer if you find
yourself saying about
your relationships about your work life
about your finances about what you'd
like to see even in society at large
someone if you find yourself saying
someone has to do something
stop stop stop saying it because nine
times out of ten that person has to be
you or it won't happen end of story
I'm talking to everyone out there
conservatives in the entertainment
industry and academia on politicized
science grants may be high profile
athletes no one is going to do it if you
don't this is the main piece of advice
that I could get if I could give to
anyone I don't know I'm 31 years young
who wants your advice from a 31 year old
but half the time when we get these
questions from people it can be answered
very simply do something stopping the
complainer stop being the person who
screams that someone has to do something
and be the guy or the girl who doesn't
that's it this week go forward be the
guy who does something hey if you like
this video you first up should probably
seek counseling but you should subscribe
or hit the notification bell or watch
one of these videos that's playing what
the truth is I don't know what any of
that means anymore if you try and
subscribe it's a notification bell you
won't be notified and if you try to
click one of these videos it's just
going to take you to BuzzFeed boldly fat
prods as they get carried out of their
houses relate to break down the north
wall and they get carried out in a land
well tarp I don't know what's happening
on YouTube I know what's happening with
mug Club ladders credit.com slash monk
let me get to watch The Daily Show one
hour every single day not just clips
along with like 15 other shows for 69
dollars annually if your student and/or
veteran or military and you get to keep
us here on YouTube for free because we
can we can irritate them by your support
it's worth it right